economía en francés 24 me acompañan en
el estudio jorge hurtado en nicaragua
para el mundo jorge vamos a comenzar en
eeuu porque el presidente joe biden
nomino para un segundo mandato al
presidente de la reserva federal así que
se trata de jerome power un ex banquero
y veterano de la política monetaria en
eeuu powell de 68 años es un republicano
moderado que estuvo enfrentado con
donald trump durante su mandato powell
llegó a la reserva federal como
gobernador en 2012 y antes fue socio de
the carlyle group una de las mayores
firmas de capital privado del mundo
bailén apostó la continuidad de una
política económica con enfoque en la
estabilidad y la creación de empleo
según la casa blanca
santiago bajo el mandato de powell se
han creado casi 6 millones de puestos de
trabajo así como el aumento de los
salarios el segundo mandato de powell
debe ser confirmado por el senado en un
momento clave para la economía con el
alza de los precios del consumidor y la
escasez causada por la crisis de la
cadena de suministro el segundo mandato
de powell iniciará en febrero y los
próximos meses serán cruciales para
determinarse su legado será como el
presidente de la fed que leo el empleo o
como el que dejo que la inflación se
disparara y se estableciera como un
problema crónico este último es
probablemente el desafío más grande para
ello escuchemos wing sabemos que la alta
inflación pasa facturas a las familias
especialmente a las que tienen menos
capacidad para hacer frente al mayor
coste de los artículos de primera
necesidad como los alimentos la vivienda
y el transporte utilizaremos nuestras
herramientas tanto para apoyar la
economía y un mercado laboral fuerte
como para evitar que la inflación más
alta se consolide santiago tras la
noticia de la nominación las acciones
estadounidenses alcanzaron máximos
históricos los rendimientos de los bonos
del tesoro también subieron y el dólar
se fortaleció hablemos ahora del
petróleo jorge porque los precios
subieron luego de una semana que
estuvieron a la baja prácticamente todos
a qué se debe bueno el mercado del
petróleo subió por la preocupación de
que la organización de países
exportadores de petróleo y sus aliados
pudieran retener barriles en respuesta a
una liberación de las reservas
estratégicas de petróleo o también a un
nuevo pico de pandemia que afecta a
europa y que podría detener la demanda
la opep ha dicho que planea un aumento
gradual de la producción de unos 400 mil
barriles diarios cada mes
eeuu considera la liberación de más de
35 millones de barriles de sus reservas
según fuentes de bloomberg la
publicación afirma que india también
analizar la liberación de la existencia
de petróleo algunos países miembros de
la opep están inconformes con el uso de
reservas estatales ya que según ellos se
debe usar en durante algún tipo de
emergencia pero ahora se gestiona para
enfriar el aumento de los precios y
hablemos ahora de brasil aquí en nuestra
región allí prevén un aumento en la
inflación bueno un sondeo divulgado por
el banco central confirma que por
primera vez se espera una tasa de
precios de dos dígitos en brasil según
el boletín focus un sondeo que es
realizado por el banco central donde se
consulta semanalmente a economistas
bancos e instituciones financieras esta
trigésima esta sería la 33ª semana
consecutiva en que el mercado elevó su
proyección para la inflación en brasil
hace unos días el gobierno informó que
la inflación de octubre fue el 125 por
ciento la mayor tasa para el mes en 20
años el índice de precios al consumidor
como alza de 10 67% en 12 meses y de 8 a
24 por ciento en lo que va de este año
el repunte es impulsado por los aumentos
de los combustibles en los mercados
internacionales y a la mayor demanda
global del mismo en brasil el
combustible ha sufrido un aumento del
40% en los últimos meses los alimentos
acumulan una subida del 12% en el último
año y esta alza hizo que el 85 por
ciento los brasileños disminuyeron el
consumo de uno o más alimentos según un
reporte de la fundación getúlio vargas
bueno no son cifras muy alentadoras pero
hablemos ahora de los indicadores como
las faldas principales bolsas arrancamos
con wall street que tocó récord tras la
nominación de gerard powell para
continuar como presidente de la reserva
federal en europa la bolsa alemana cayó
luego de que angela merkel aseguró que
necesitan restricciones más fuertes para
controlar una ola de kobe 19 y en
latinoamérica la bolsa de santiago cerró
con un aumento del 9,69 por ciento el
mayor alza diaria en 13 años esto
después de los resultados de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
en chile y cifra del día para el cierre
que nos trae hoy bueno la cifra de 178 y
entonces él lo que aumentó el número de
ofertas maliciosas en el contexto de
black friday y el cyber monday el 26 el
29 de noviembre esto según check point
software technologies una firma que
analiza el internet y que está pendiente
de este tipo de páginas maliciosas bueno
hay que estar muy atentos muchas gracias
jorge es todo por el momento aquí en la
economía de france 24 ya viene el debate
[Música]